anyway i was thinking about how it's the
first game in the franchise you know
time wise and how that means that this
link here is the first hero to be well
the hero the first one to wield the
master sword the first one to aid zelda
in her quest the first one to defeat
the malice of demise actually he
straight up defeats demise himself so
clearly
this guy is a huge deal to the franchise
like
of course all links are important to
their respective zelda games but if we
were to rank them based upon their
importance to the franchise as a whole
it would go something like this
base level links would be the ones that
only fought one-off villains that only
appeared in like one game then the links
with the repeating villains would take
the second tier links that fought ganon
would be
right above that and then finally on the
top would be the links that shaped the
meta-narrative of the entire zelda
franchise as we know it
up here on this pedestal are just two
links the hero of the skies who
literally started the entire timeline
and the hero of time who
splintered it but what if i told you
that these two links
might be more closely connected than you
think let's take a look at the hero of
the skies real quick
also for those of you who have somehow
stayed completely spoiler free for the
last 10 years since skyward sword
initially released please consider this
a spoiler warning for the contents of
this video which will be spoiling
in depth the contents of skyward sword
also also i have an important
announcement to make at the end of the
video so for my subscribers
and for those of you who are here often
enough that you should go ahead and
click that subscribe button anyway
you'll want to make sure you stick
around to the end of the video to catch
that also also also
like this video if you like this video
okay here we go the hero of the skies is
pretty similar to the hero of time right
i mean both of them are extremely
influential to the timeline they're both
master sword wielding links they both
defeat incarnations of demise and they
both travel
through time in order to save the world
from the hatred of demise
see to recap in a nutshell at the end of
skyward sword link successfully wishes
upon the absolute power of the triforce
for the destruction of demise
this works and the goddesses literally
send the isle of the goddess crashing
down from skyloft onto the surface
squishing the imprisoned also known as
demise to death
all seems well and good after this but
the heroic duo forgot about one little
thing
demise's top goon girohim was still out
there running around planning evil stuff
so sure enough he pops up out of nowhere
and steals princess zelda because that's
what villains do in zelda games and then
takes her through the gate of time
into the past to resurrect demise back
then you know before the big avocado was
squished into guacamole girohim uses
zelda's essence and is successful in
resurrecting his master
even though link also rushed through the
gate of time and tried his hardest to
stop it but even though
giroheim's plan did actually succeed
extremely well
long story short it didn't really matter
because link was able to beat demise
anyway
at demise's full power after which the
essence of the demon king was then
absorbed into the master sword and
placed in the pedestal so that he would
never
again bother the world just kidding he
cursed the bloodline of hylia to be
eternally bound to fight his
incarnations for the rest of time right
before he died
anyway the part of the story that i'd
like to emphasize in this video is that
link
the hero traveled through time to save
the world
the hero through time now taking note of
that let's put a pin in it and fast
forward to the next time the master
sword is needed in the franchise
when ganondorf makes his first
chronological appearance in ocarina of
time
as many already know and some are about
to find out
link is told by zelda that he needs to
defeat the man with the evil eyes
because
well because zelda had a bad dream and
said so anyway link accesses the master
sword beyond the door of time and upon
drawing it is immediately put to sleep
for seven
long years he awakens in the future
which is now
a gritty reality that's been completely
corrupted by ganondorf so turns out
zelda's dream was spot on throughout the
course of the game link travels between
his original child
timeline and the future adult timeline
in order to fully cleanse the world from
ganondorf's evil
but the real kicker for all these time
shenanigans comes at the end of the game
when zelda who feels bad about the whole
you know denying a child their childhood
and plunging them headfirst into several
life and death situations within which
victory would never be assured in combat
would be necessary to survive
so as an apology of sorts she sends link
back to his quote-unquote original
timeline before any of the events of the
game happened and thus creates the
infamous timeline split in the zelda
franchise
this final disappearance of link from
the adult timeline
is what merited him with the official
title of the hero of time
or did it you see he wasn't called the
hero of time at the end of the game
actually he was called the hero of time
when he pulled the sword from the
pedestal for the first time and the way
he was given the title is a bit
strange see it wasn't enough for link to
just be the reincarnation of the spirit
of the hero
raru states that only one who is worthy
of the title hero of time can pull the
sword from the pedestal which he clearly
wasn't at first
he also says that link was too young to
be the hero of time and that's why he
was put to sleep
for seven years until he woke up at
about the age of 16 to 17 years old
he also specifically credits the master
sword itself
with choosing the hero of time something
that we see happening again with the
link from twilight princess
now this doesn't sound that out of the
ordinary at first glance especially for
a zelda game which are known for
fantasies and legends and magic but it
starts to take on a different meaning
when you
do like me and overthink everything we
just talked about see raru's words imply
that there was already a standard for
who can wield the master sword
at least when it comes to his age and
this criteria was referred to
as the hero of time and was to be
detailed by none other than the master
sword itself in other words the master
sword is responsible for coming up with
and enforcing the concept of the hero of
time
thanks to skyward sword we know that the
master sword is indeed
sentient and capable of making
calculations and decisions just like
this one because it had a spirit named
phi living inside it who was able to
make link wait until he was around 17
years old to wield the sword
now the question is where would fee have
gotten this
standard for the hero of time and why is
it important while the last time the
sword was used was in skyward sword
and get this that link was 17 years old
according to his character artist
the last and only other link that the
master sword was in contact with was a
17 year old boy who traveled through
time to defeat the demon king
a hero through time a hero
of time all of a sudden the age
requirement doesn't seem so random does
it
fai created that criteria and titled it
the hero of time because she was looking
for the link that traveled through time
she was looking for her master and if
her master really was the one who
inspired this age requirement and even
the title hero of time
wouldn't that make him the first hero of
time
this could be further proven by the
sheikah legend that sheikh tells link
after he returns from the chamber of
sages
she says that he really does look quote
like the legendary hero of time
and while this could be interpreted as
just simply a fulfillment of sheikah
prophecy
that doesn't necessarily disprove what
we're talking about after all legends
have to be built on past events right
of course this is all just my theory
though what did you guys think are there
actually
two heroes of time or is this just
another classic case of overthinking
everything from your favorite bandit let
me know in the comments below and thank
you so much for watching now i do have
an announcement to make that i mentioned
i would be making earlier on the video
and that is that i am going live with a
second channel in addition to this
channel called bandit plays that's going
to be more gameplay or more personality
focused the idea behind it is not to
feel like a second channel
but more like a co-channel where i play
the games there that i will then talk
about or theorize about here
like i do normally it's super exciting
kind of nerve wracking but ultimately
just something i've wanted to do for a
really long time
actually i used to have let's plays on
this channel that i took down once i
decided to go a different direction with
my content but anyway i wanted to ask
you guys
two things one if you happen to be
interested in seeing me play some games
i would really appreciate it if you
would consider subscribing to the
channel bandit plays i don't expect this
at all
of course but if even one percent of my
subscribers on this channel followed me
to bandit plays that would at least give
it some momentum to
start off with instead of starting from
absolute zero so to those of you who may
be thinking about giving a sub to the
new channel
thank you so much i'll link to it in the
description below second i
guess for the same group of people if
you are interested in watching me play
games would you do me a huge favor and
let me know in the comments below
on this video what games you would like
to see me play i did buy skyward sword
hd the other day and i've been holding
off on that one in the case that you
guys do want to see me play that game
but i didn't want to go for it unless
you guys wanted it because there are
already a whole lot of really awesome
let's plays going on right now about the
game
ultimately i am open to playing
literally anything nintendo or not any
genre horror or not
you name it i'll be playing it anyway
that's the end of the announcement so
once again to those of you who will be
helping out thank you so much in advance
and as always a huge thanks goes out to
my bandit crew of which i have new names
to announce please say hello to
jemmy and ree rector who have recently
joined the ranks of my elite if you
watching are interested in helping the
videos that you want to see get created
on this channel please check out that
join button below any of my videos or
the links to my patreon and merch pages
in the description below also down there
the links to my social media pages so
come follow me on twitter
and instagram for a bunch of cool stuff
and giveaways that i do every now and
then that's all i've got for you in this
video so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day
this is masentendo bandit signing out
hey everyone bandit here with the recent
release of skyward sword hd
it made me start to think about link and
how wait why are you looking at me that
way
[Music]
do you ever feel like time isn't flowing
naturally
anyway